gehen solange in unser bild lagezentrum
zu unserer militärexperten maximilian
kiewel der uns der sie auf den stand
bringt über die lage in diesem
schrecklichen ukraine krieg
[Musik]
seit tagen sehen wir russische truppen
auf dem vormarsch sehen russische panzer
und sehen auf diesen russischen
militärfahrzeugen diese mysteriösen
diese merkwürdigen markierungen vor
allem dieses markante z was wir zum
beispiel hier immer wieder sehen das
wollen wir ihnen heute erklären und
ihnen helfen zu verstehen warum die
russen diese markierungen auf ihre
militärfahrzeuge gemacht haben und was
sie eben genau bedeuten dafür muss man
einmal verstehen militärfahrzeuge
soldaten die bewegen sich im feld und
die haben natürlich eine große
herausforderung im dunkeln in der
dämmerung wenn sie durch die dünne und
schmalen schmitz schlitze ihrer
fahrzeuge gucken nämlich zu erkennen das
fahrzeug dagegen über ist das eigentlich
freund oder ist das feindbeschuss sich
womöglich meine eigenen kameraden oder
beschießt sich dorthin gegner nato
truppen westliche truppen die haben
dafür heute vor allem elektronische
geräte an sich hängen die eben helfen zu
identifizieren ist das da drüben mein
freien mein freund oder ist es mein
feind die russen das merken und sehen
wir jetzt in diesen tagen die verfügung
über diese technologie zumindest für
ihre fahrzeuge offenbar nicht und
greifen deswegen zu einer methodik zu
einer technik die aussieht wie aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg in dem sie mit farbe
ihrer eigenen militärfahrzeuge an mal
und so zu verstehen geben wer zu uns aus
russischer sicht gehört und wer nicht
und dabei stehen diese zeichen zum
beispiel jeder set hier das ohr oder
hier unten das set im kasten für
unterschiedliche militäreinheiten aus
unterschiedlichen schwieriger begriff
russischen militär bezirken also einfach
gesprochen woher diese fahrzeuge kommen
bevor sie eben in die eu in die ukraine
einmarschiert sind und dort für tot und
für zerstörung suchen wir haben ihn bei
3 rausgesucht die besonders markant sind
und die wir vor allem gerade besonders
oft im einsatz sehen einmal ich habe es
gesagt das set und das set diese
soldaten die haben eigentlich den
weitesten weg hinter sich denn die
kommen aus dem östlichen militär bezirk
russlands und der wir haben den fall x
hier nach rechts gemacht müsste
eigentlich noch viel weiter gehen die
kommen teilweise aus fernost vom pazifik
den ganzen weg quer durch russland
zurückgelegt um jetzt eben in der
ukraine für blut und zerstörung zu
suchen das so dass wir immer wieder
sehen das steht für truppen wir haben es
hier 1 markiert die aus belarus
einmarschiert sind die also feuer von
russland nach belarus gefahren sind und
dann eben jetzt aus dem norden die
ukraine angreifen und gleich ist hier
das set im kasten nicht zu verwechseln
mit dem z ohne kasten das wiederum
truppen die aus dem südlichen
militärbezirks also zb von der krim
vorgestoßen sind und eben jetzt in der
ukraine angreifen dieses mysteriöse und
merkwürdige panzer abz der russin das
führt mittlerweile in russland selbst zu
einem ganz bitteren kult den ich ihnen
zeigen möchte denn die russen selbst die
kleben sich mittlerweile einige russen
muss man natürlich sagen auf ihre
fahrzeuge zu hause die gleichen
buchstaben mit denen ihre
militärfahrzeuge gerade in der ukraine
für so viel elend sorgen oder auch ich
gehe mal hier rüber und markieren das
gibt mittlerweile in russland ja buttons
zu kaufen die man sich dann an die
klamotten kleben und heften kann und
damit eben die unterstützung für die
eigenen truppen ausrüsten kann das ganze
geht auch noch weiter ich zeige ihnen
dass es gibt mittlerweile bei social
media hier mit ton anderes video wo eben
die wir springen noch mal zurück ich
zeige ihnen von anfang an wo die jugend
putins jugend in russland hier sehen wir
ist das set am anfang ihre solidarität
mit dem präsidenten ausdrückt und mit
den eigenen truppen ein ganz
merkwürdiges bizarres video wo man sich
fragt wie freiwillig sind wirklich die
leute in diesem video und wissen sie
wirklich was da gerade in der ukraine
passiert was russische truppen
ausrichten meine reporterin die lilly
von der osten und greta bauen die haben
sich nochmal genauer angeguckt woher
kommt dieser merkwürdige z hype gerade
und wer steckt eigentlich dahinter und
die sind auf eine ganz spannende person
gestoßen eine person die ganz früh auf
instagram bei social media angefangen
hat diesen z content zu teilen und eben
dafür zu sorgen dass die russen sich dem
anschließen die frau die wir hier sehen
die heißt wir sehen es auch hier ich mag
ihnen das war das macht es spannend
maria butina und das was sie hier sehen
dieses ganze schrift dokument das ist
eine anklage aus den usa denn diese frau
die sie hier sehen die seit wochen schon
diesen z content teilt ist eine
geheimagenten die für wladimir putin in
den usa spioniert hat 2018 festgenommen
wurde vom fbi als agentin festgenommen
wurde deren ziel war ist die
republikanische partei zu unterwandern
war der jahrelang im einsatz für putin
für den fsb ist verhaftet worden hier
der mug shot damals so ist sie
vorgeführt worden den usa und jetzt ich
mach das bild noch mal klar dass wir es
besser erkennen können so also posiert
sie heute bei social media und sie sehen
zu der hier dieser buchstabe z eben die
solidarität und diese merkwürdige
propaganda diese ja das brain watch in
der der russen die das was hier
stattfinden soll um eben die eigenen
leute zu mobilisieren für diesen
angriffskrieg für den es keine
rechtfertigung gibt zum abschluss möchte
ich ihnen noch beunruhigender aufnahmen
zeigen die uns erreichen
über israelische satelliten ein
unternehmen das hat diese bilder hier
geteilt heute in der nacht denn wenn sie
diesen krieg in der ukraine verfolgen
dann ist ihnen vielleicht 1 aufgefallen
die luftwaffe die russische luftwaffe
diese 500 600 700 jets über die wladimir
putin verfügt die haben bis jetzt nur
eine ganz geringe rolle bei diesem
angriffskrieg gespielt kommen kaum zum
einsatz und man fragt sich eigentlich
warum und jetzt gibt es neue
satellitenbilder und die belegen dass
offenbar massenhaft hier zb mit 29 hier
nochmal mit 29 auf flug feldern an der
grenze zur ukraine und in belarus
gesammelt werden und die große
befürchtung dass hier dutzende und
hunderte jets gerade aufgetankt werden
mit den koordinaten versorgt werden und
werden zum beispiel am wochenende tod
und zerstörung in die ukraine zu bringen
mit diesen leider düsteren aussichten
muß man ja sagen verabschieden wir uns
ja aus dem lagezentrum und geben zurück
zu bild live